[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans le grand studio
du figaro on est en direct
on est ensemble c'est figaro live et on
attend vos points de vue en particulier
sur le black friday faut-il le repousser
faut-il maintenir faut-il encadrer ou
faut-il le supprimer on en débat ce soir
avec vous et avec mathieu sous pierre
bonsoir mathieu expert auprès de la
fondation jean jaurès et ancien membre
entre autres du cabinet de myriam el
khomri et communicants de choc
je leur faut-il le souligner face à vous
un journaliste de choc
l'auteur d'un livre qui a beaucoup
choqué en tout cas les gens dont il a
dont il parle
le tout-paris sérieux en tout cas et
informe et fait la promotion 200
ouvrages et c'est mérité c'est
absolument à lire mélenchon la chute
comment la france insoumise s'est
effondré cette aux éditions du rocher on
va peut-être y revenir justement tout à
l'heure à travers un autre débat une
autre actualité faut-il un moratoire sur
l'immigration
c'est ce que demande non pas la france
insoumise mais les républicains mais
d'abord un sujet qui pourrait intéresser
les pubs la france a soumis c'est le
black friday
la question qu'on vous pose sur twitter
ses fautes heel le repousser on vous
pose cette question parce que la
proposition émane du ministre de
l'économie lui même bruno le maire ont
l'écoutent c'était à l'assemblée
nationale et donc je voudrais appeler
tous les acteurs économiques que ce soit
la grande distribution que ce soient des
acteurs du commerce digital au sens des
responsabilités en imposant cette simple
question est ce que vraiment vendredi
prochain c'est la bonne date pour
organiser un black friday
ma réponse est non et j'espère qu'ils me
comprendront aussi j'aurai l'occasion de
leur en parler pour leur demander de
faire preuve de sens des responsabilités
et examiner toutes les possibilités de
décaler cette opération qui n'a pas de
sens dans les circonstances actuelles
alors certains sont d'accord parmi les
grandes enseignes avec bruno le maire
c'est le cas d'alexandre bompard le
patron de carrefour leclerc se dit prêt
à ce prêt à se rallier à cette idée
c'est tout le monde est d'accord pour
l'instant il y en a un qui est pas
d'accord c'est le patron du medef
geoffroy roux de bézieux
tout est imaginable n'est pas huit jours
avant il ya des supermarchés qui ont
préparé leur catalogue il ya des
e-commerçants parle beaucoup d' amazon
mais c'est la maison c'est 20 % du
commerce ya plein dit commerçant le
français qui ont préparé leur promotion
il ya même des commerces fermés qui sont
prêts à ouvrir avec le black friday
donc on peut discuter du black friday
par le principe mais pas huit jours
avant je pense que c'est pas raisonnable
qu'il faut pas que cela soit un prétexte
pour nous dire on repousse le black
friday donc vous n'ouvrez pas le 27 1 ce
qui peut être ce qui alors il y en a en
tout cas qui lui critique le principe
même du bois du black friday
c'est le patron de l'ufc que choisir ils
demandent à l'état d'encadrer cette
opération commerciale
il dénonce je cite des promotions bideau
son président à l'entendre à lire on a
plutôt l'impression adrien matou qui
seraient favorables à sa suppression est
ce que c'est le point de vue du
journaliste de marianne que vous êtes
ah oui plutôt oui alors je sais pas si
on peut décider de la suppression du
black friday puisque c'est un peu une
initiative privée quand même mais déjà
je voudrais revenir sur l'intervention
de bruno le maire alors je suis d'accord
sur le fait qu'il doit déjà voilà j'ai
ouï je suis je vais expliquer pourquoi
je suis pour sa suppression mais déjà je
suis un petit peu gêné voire agacés de
voir bruno le maire qui ne cessent de
supplier de demander de quémander mais
qu'il semble ne rien pouvoir décider
terre que j'ai l'impression qu'il met
toujours en scène sont en puissance
l'impuissance du politique à avoir une
influence sur l'économie en mais
vraiment je trouve ça assez gênant quoi
c'est c'est un ministre régalien qui a
comme un ver sic est en effet un des
mystères les plus prestigieux du
gouvernement et qui toujours est en
train de supplier les acteurs
économiques de bien vouloir faire ce
qu'il souhaite
en réalité il y à il ya sans doute des
moyens pour l'état six avaient planifié
s'ils savaient prévoir 2 par exemple 2
de mobiliser la répression des fraudes
pour limiter le black friday et je
trouve ça toujours un petit peu gênant
de voir le ministre demande et de la
bonne volonté aux acteurs économiques
sur la mise en scène de l'impuissance
bruno le maire peut-il faire autrement
monsieur vous clouer les consignes
ministérielles en fait super accord avec
adrien il se trouve qu'on est en
économie de marché
on n'est pas en économie administrée et
donc que le marché a toute sa place mais
que malgré tout même en économie de
marché
si le ministre de l'économie et des
finances dit écoutez le black rain le
black friday pardon la semaine prochaine
ça va poser des difficultés on voit bien
qu'en réalité les acteurs économiques a
fortiori dans un contexte où
l'interventionnisme public est très
puissant ou les deniers publics coule à
flots on voit bien qu'en réalité les
décideurs économiques vont devoir
composer avec cette parole politique
donc même si pour de vrai il n'ya pas
dans les textes quelque chose qui
permette aux pouvoirs publics d'entraver
cette initiative privée commerciale
on voit bien que ça va pas être si
évident que c est ce qui est arrivé à la
lèze part à part la mise en scène est ce
que vous êtes
la mise en scène je reprend les termes
d'adrien de l'impuissance de bruno le
maire
je suis donc je reviens un peu
différemment ce que je dis je pense
qu'il n'y a pas aujourd'hui d'un
puissance publique je pense même que la
crise sanitaire depuis le mois de mars a
été restauré l'autorité du politique à
partir du mois de mars
il a fallu prendre des décisions d'une
ampleur inédite avec une réactivité
inédite et tout le monde s'est couché
face à l'autorité retrouvé par le
pouvoir politique
il n'y a pas eu un grand décideur
économique pour s'opposer à ce qui s'est
passé à partir du mois de mars où on a
mis pour des raisons sanitaires
l'économie sous cloche personne n'a
moufté pas là c'est quand même pas la
première fois que bruno le maire supplie
des grandes entreprises
de bien vouloir par exemple je crois que
sur les délocalisations était déjà
intervenu en disant vraiment j'appelle
j'en appelle au patriotisme des grands
groupes etc
ensuite effectivement le politique a
repris de l'autorité à la faveur de la
crise ceci dit je vois mal les
entrepreneurs français s'opposer aux
plans de soutien massifs de l'économie
qu'il aurait été proposé à dire que
youri le confinement certes heurte
beaucoup de petits commerçants qui
d'ailleurs ne ne se prive pas de
contester plus râler mais les grands
groupes n'ont pas vraiment à se plaindre
de ce que dit ce que veut dire c'est
qu'entre guillemets le pouls de l'état a
peut acheter la décision qu'il prenait 2
de supprimer de suspendre par jacques
fayolle eux l'activité économique nous
avons justement à wil et puis le
confinement ben oui enfin ce que je veux
dire c'est que certes le l'état a montré
sa puissance d'intervention dans
l'économie avec avec la crise mais
contre monnaie sonnante et truqué son
autorité
oui mais ceci dit c'est une action
économique qui est en faveur des
entreprises en réalité ouais enfin à
ceci près que dans d'autres pays le
débat a été d'une autre teneur
beaucoup d'acteurs économiques faisant
valoir les intérêts économiques en
disant attention
ok il faut préserver la santé dans
cinquante deux personnes pour le
confinement mais cela doit-il se faire
au détriment de l'économie et même trump
lui-même feu photo m il ya six mois il
avant de croire donc ça notre débat
disent avoir un autre juge ne relance le
débat sur donald mai mais en
l'occurrence le croit banque et la
supplie que vous exagérez un peu parce
que la supplique et pacy larmoyante que
ça du tout non il s'agit juste de poser
la question et on revient que si roux de
bézieux montent au créneau aussi vite je
trouve un peu gonflé huit jours si
précisément dans le contexte qui est le
nôtre où on nous invite à une réactivité
permanente et où le monde de
l'entreprise depuis quelques années que
le termes d'agilité à la bouche
je trouve un peu gonflé en fait
d'expliquer que les jours avant c'est un
peu tard mais d'un autre côté c'est vrai
que des entreprises ont plutôt montré
une belle réactivité depuis le début de
l'ère du confinement donc joue on a
compris de quel camp vous et tire entre
le choix entre reports maintien et
suppression mathieu je n'ai pas posé la
question je suis dans le camp d'adrien
je me rallie à rien ça mais pour des
raisons simples on est aujourd'hui en
train de débattre du black friday dans
un contexte effectivement très singulier
mais ça fait déjà quand même quel est
alors d'abord ça fait relativement peu
de temps qu'on a nous en france importé
tradition du black friday et je dirais
aussi vite importé aussi vite contestée
parce qu'on en sait enfin tout le monde
admet ou à peu près quand même que le
black friday est probablement le
l'archétype de la débauche commerciale
du système totalement délirant dans
lequel on s'était un peu gangréné et au
moment quand même du confinement
on a tous dit jupiter disant moi le
premier qu'on avait à reparler des
manuels maquereau ou oui pardon on avait
à repenser le système qu'on avait à tout
le moins questionnés le système qu'on
était probablement partie économiquement
dans quelque chose là aussi d'un peu
délirant et qu'il fallait reprendre un
petit peu la main sur ce que le marché
nous avez nous avait laissés accomplir
et là on est en train de repartir dans
des délires consumériste approche de
noël entre black friday et noël
on voit bien que la marque travaille
avec myriam el khomri être contre les dr
consumer risque veut on peut on peut on
peut seulement de quoi sur le fait de
l'ouverture le 22 la question que
soulève geoffroy roux de bézieux
l'ouverture des petits commerces
le 27 novembre vous y êtes fait avoir ou
pas non parce que en fait à mon avis là
au niveau sanitaire
enfin en tout cas si c'est dans le
contexte du black friday avec des avec
des promotions à tout va fatalement
légendes vont se précipiter et c'est
bien normal dans l'est dans les magasins
pour faire leurs courses de noël et
profiter des promotions et ben je suis
désolé mais on s'est quand même pas
confiné 12 depuis plusieurs semaines
pour venir se refiler le virus en une
journée face à sermonner wc complètement
contre-productif du point de vue
sanitaire
donc on peut imaginer des solutions pour
les pour les commerces mais ce serait un
non sens ce serait vraiment donc vos
faveurs du premier de favorables au 1er
décembre par exemple par exemple eh oui
monsieur
alors moi même je ne suis pas je fus que
je ne suis pas spécialiste de questions
sanitaires et je pense que il n'ya que
les autorités sanitaires qui peuvent
aujourd'hui dire quelle est la bonne
date pour éviter que le
l'épidémie ne repartent pas ce que cinq
ans c'est encore les autorités
sanitaires je ne suis pas il faut
complotistes et j'ai entièrement
confiance dans les autorités sanitaires
sans nier le fait que le débat peut
avoir des fiances avec les autorités
sanitaires sans être complotistes ou pas
alors je jauge en tout cas je conçois
qu'il puisse y avoir un débat au sein
des instances médicales
mais c'est pas parce qu'il y ait un
débat que derrière ensuite il ne peut
pas y avoir à minima un consensus ou en
tout état de cause une position
dominante qui guident derrière la
décision publique et je pense qu'il est
très dangereux de deux d'avoir un débat
médical comme ça sur la sur la place
publique qui ensuite a même quasiment
chaque citoyen à se faire après avoir
été entraîneur de l'équipe de france de
football
professeur d'infectiologie spécialiste
en infectiologie et donc d'avoir une
idée très précise sur les dates de
déconfinement et les modalités de
dérivés norvège en temps je suis tout à
fait votre raisonnement mais à partir du
moment où les décisions médicales ont un
impact sur la vie quotidienne des
citoyens est ce que justement il peut y
avoir un débat qui soit un débat citoyen
sur ses décisions salutaires et sédition
alors la démocratie sanitaire c'est un
vrai sujet comment est-ce qu'on a encore
un espace de débat démocratique
quand on est en état d'urgence ou en
tout cas pris dans une situation
relativement inextricable alors cet
argument valley à mon sens au printemps
quand l'épidémie a pris tout le monde de
court dire qu'en mars avril
et d'ailleurs la discipline collective a
été très grande parce que chacun a
compris qu'on était confrontée à un
phénomène inédit et que personne n'avait
pu anticiper évidemment six mois après
c'est plus compliqué d'invoquer les
mêmes arguments alors que six mois après
normalement on devrait avoir
alors je dis pas que les pouvoirs
publics ont été fautifs de ne pas
anticiper une deuxième vague parce qu'en
réalité la deuxième vague tout le monde
savait qu'elle arriverait on savait pas
comme tout le monde
en tout cas beaucoup pensaient qu'elle
arriverait on ne savait pas quand ni
selon quelles modalités et la de ce
point de vue là elle n'a pas été si
facile que cela à gérer tous les pays où
à peu près se sont retrouvés confrontés
à elle en étant un peu démuni mais je
dire au delà de ça sur le principe de la
démocratie sanitaire du fait qu' il
puisse y avoir un débat démocratique
autour de la situation sanitaire du pays
je pense qu'on est un peu défaillant
aujourd'hui le parlement par exemple
légitimement réclame sa place dans le
débat et on peut pas dire qu'ils aient
qu'elle lui soit donné de façon
importante je crois que votre je crois
pas je suis sûr j'ai cru un intéressant
dossier sur la question dans notre
journal justement sur
l'impact que le pouvoir sanitaire
pouvait avoir sur le recul ou non de la
vie démocratique
en fait moi je trouve que la difficulté
est d'autant plus grande quand le
pouvoir sanitaires ou en tout cas les
autorités sanitaires semblent divisés
moi je pense que ce serait beaucoup plus
simple de faire des arbitrages que toute
façon l'arbitrage central tout le monde
le connaît de vie économique
préservation de la santé publique
mais si comment dire si les différents
médecins urgentistes infectiologues
s'étaient emparés tous d'une même voix
je pense que tous les français auraient
les clés en main pour finalement faire
faire ses arbitrages là or là quand on
entend certains médecins dire il y aura
une deuxième vague y aura pas de
deuxième vague le confinement et
justifiait le confinement était
justifiée l'espèce de cacophonie mumbai
à un débat sanitaire également bien
salaire antérieur à l'art sanitaire en
dix ans et on peut continuer à vivre
bien sûr des traitements c'est ce qu'ils
disent banon peut pas laisser entrer ya
passablement le problème entre
guillemets acer que on ouvre le débat en
disant est ce qu'il faut et la parole
sally terre est si fier totalement mais
il n'y a pas de paroles sanitaire
vraiment univoque quoi il n'empêche que
la stratégie sanitaire a été à peu près
la même dans tous les pays
à quelques exceptions incompris
l'exception de la suède qui est en train
d'arriver pays européens pas forcément
tous les pays asiatiques
non non parce que faiblement finement a
pas été non c'est vrai un dur henry ce
partout on a un rapport à la réalité
épidémie guinée malkin qui n'est pas le
même partout mais globalement quand même
décisionnel globalement confrontés à la
même situation tous les pays où à peu
près ont pris la même décision
on donne la parole à nos internautes je
salue marie babineau chardons bleus
notamment qui nous ont rejoints soit sur
youtube soit sur le chat du figaro vont
continuer à débattre avec nous vous
continuez à commenter et réagir mari
nous dire tenir l'activité commerciale
ne semble pas une solution en ce moment
achetons si nous pouvons et babineau
nous dit conséquences de la fermeture
des rayons non essentiels dans les
grandes surfaces
le gouvernement prend des décisions il
n'assume pas les résultats est ce que
c'est parce que ça aussi points non
parce que dire sur le black friday par
exemple ou notamment black le black
friday de façon
moi je conteste même son utilité en
général parce que vous avez cités de
soleure le président de ufc que choisir
est en fait ils ont regardé ils ont fait
des études très intéressantes sur sur
les fameuses réductions du black friday
alors déjà c'est pas forcément des noms
c'est même pas du tout des produits
essentiels puisque c'est essentiellement
de de l'électroménager des écrans plats
etc
et en plus les réductions sont les
producteurs les producteurs de
télévision et électroménager vous
remercie de pas considérer que ce sont
deux je pense qu'on fait je pense qu'on
peut vivre sans télévision et
l'ordinateur est pas ça en vidéo sur
ordinateur il s'est compliqué mais mais
en tout cas les études du lieu c'est que
choisir montre que les en scène en
général qu'est ce qu'elles font elles
augmentent les prix quelques semaines
avant le black friday aide les baisses
brutalement et finalement il ya une
baisse de la moyenne des réductions
d'effectifs sur chaque article est
inférieure à 2% absolue mais quand même
pas le black friday est une fumisterie
ça justifie pas se précipiter dans les
rayons et heureusement le combat un mois
de noël
on comprend très on ne comprendrait pas
en fait que toutes les enseignes brad
évidemment ce sera un non sens
bradley biens et produits que les
français vont s'empresser d'acheter
ensuite nicole nous dit il ferait mieux
de laisser les petits commerces ouverts
oui alors enfin sens à ce que disait
sans aucun doute si le critère essentiel
évidemment c'est l'intérêt des petits
commerces et effectivement c'est très
difficile c'est un cas un confinement ça
pouvait éventuellement passer la
question est de savoir dans quelle
mesure un certain nombre de petits
commerces vont survivre au second
confinement il est même au deuxième
confinement parce que on pourrait en
avoir d'autres azer on pourrait en avoir
d'autres un peu plus tard c'est un vrai
sujet et en même temps on est en train
de jouer un jeu un tout petit peu
dangereux le fameux jeu du des gros des
grands et des petits
or il n'y a pas de raison d'opposer en
fait les différents acteurs économiques
entre il est impératif alors on a
polémiqué sur la notion de biens
essentiels si je pense qu'on peut quand
même comprendre ce que sont des biens
essentiels malgré tout je lis beaucoup
de lire mais je sais me passer malgré
tout deux bouquins pendant quelques
semaines je suis comme tout le monde il
faut que j'aille acheter des pâtes et
encore il ya des biens qui sont vitaux
et y en a dont on peut différer malgré
tous les usages pendant quelque temps
c'est justement sur cette notion de
l'instance essentiellement s'éloigner un
petit peu du d
donc on passe au deuxième débat mais il
n'ya pas justement l'humiliation pour
tous ceux qui travaillent sur ce qu'on a
considéré ce qu'on a classé comme biens
non essentiels
encore une fois ce débat n'a pas existé
lors du premier confinement tout le
monde est rentré chez soi pour se
protéger et tout le monde était d'accord
avec ça or la situation aujourd'hui
pourrait le justifier
on a eu un sacro-saint principaux
prétendants au printemps autour duquel
on sait tous fédérés la santé humaine la
vie humaine passe avant toute autre
considération
et aujourd'hui si on se repose la
question c'est parce qu'on se dit
peut-être que la casse économique qui va
elle même engendré une casse sociale et
plus de doha un impact sur la santé
humaine et mickaël leur vie derrière
essentiel le critère essentiel reste
celui ci malgré tout est donc l'intérêt
des petits commerçants s'est en réalité
quand même que l'on préserve la santé
humaine mais que par ailleurs dans le
même temps on leur apporte tous les
amortisseurs sociaux nécessaires c'est
votre peau de jeu également
bah oui surtout que on parle de
d'économies qui a un impact sur la sur
les gens il ya aussi le côté
psychosocial j'ai vu le chiffre des
dépressions qui est absolument ravie
sinon les confinements donc c'est même
l'arrêt de l'économie a des conséquences
sanitaires en fait mais c'est juste que
c'est pas le vide quand est ce qu'on
appelle la troisième vague
psychologiquement
les commerçants doivent t'ils reporter
le black friday est prévue le 27
novembre prochain et bien
pardon elle vous n'avez pas convaincu
les internautes disent non à 60 heures
pour cent quand j'aurai pris le pouvoir
on va aborder la deuxième question c'est
faut-il à moratoire sur l'immigration
c'est en fait une idée qui monte chez
les républicains
défendue par leur président en personne
christian jacob
depuis depuis trois ans on est on est
totalement hors contrôle sur le sur
l'immigration et est donc pour arriver à
poser tous la pl je pense qu'on pourrait
très bien dire pendant écouter trois
mois où pendant six mois mais papa mais
je pense qu'en en trois mois
le président de la république prendre
l'initiative de réunir l'ensemble des
des familles politiques et des de dire
comment mathieu questions à l'ancien
conseiller du ministère du travail
que vous êtes en 2018 il ya eu les reçus
qui dit que ont fait appel à
l'immigration pour faire pour que ces
immigrés fasse le travail que les
français ne veulent pas et remplir les
effectifs des métiers qui sont dits en
tension en 2018 qui sont des chiffres
qui sont donnés par patrick stefanini
dans son dernier livre le chômage était
de 15 3% pour les immigrés 7 2% pour le
reste de la population
est ce bien raisonnable dans ces
conditions de faire appel à la main
d'oeuvre immigrée
alors il ya plein d'associations d'idées
depuis toujours autour de la question
migratoire est il ya un retour en force
du concept de frontière aujourd'hui je
ne dis pas que c'est bien où je dis pas
que c'est mal je dis que produisait
aujourd'hui on voit bien qu'il ya une
réhabilitation de la frontière on l'a
eue avec la question de l'épidémie
attention on laisse plus rentrer
personne parce que laisser rentrer des
gens ces entités contribué à faire
circuler le virus on l'a aussi sur la
car on l'a depuis un certain nombre
d'années au tour quand même de la
question du chômage
ok la crise économique face à laquelle
on va se à laquelle on va se heurter
sera probablement très intense mais en
réalité depuis que le chômage existe
depuis qu'il a augmenté de façon
significative en gros depuis les années
70 et c'est le front national qui de ce
point de vue là a gagné la bataille des
idées
on tire un signe d'égalité entre chômage
et immigration et donc le slogan pendant
très longtemps du front national était
dire un million d'émigrés égal 1
millions de chômeurs et puis on a
actualisé ce chiffre quand ce que je
suis c'est passé à 3 millions d'accord
ce juste je joue coupe moi je vous pose
une question
c'est aujourd'hui moi je sens que je
termine là sur eux
c'est à partir du pain il se trouve que
nous avons fermé les frontières dans les
années 70 dans les années 70 suite
effectivement à une arrivée de main
d'oeuvre considérable pendant 20 ans à
partir des années 70 on a fermé les
frontières
ça n'a pas empêché le chômage
d'augmenter et par ailleurs de façon
constante de façon constante depuis 20
ou 30 ans et je me réfère de ce point de
vue-là aux travaux aux travaux du plus
grand démographe français qu hervé le
bras
la proportion d'étrangers où la
proportion d'immigrés elle est constante
et elle n'est en tout état de cause pas
plus importante aujourd'hui elle est
même plutôt moins importante aujourd'hui
qu'elle ne l'a été après guerre dans
l'entre-deux-guerres
à la fin du 19e donc il y a juste en
réalité et et en particulier dans
dans la pensée d'un certain courant
politique depuis toujours une
association entre l'immigration et un
certain nombre de mots qui sont censés
menacer notre société adrien va tous
vous consacrez je vous laisse répondre à
ce que veut dire mathieu mais vous
consacré tout un chapitre à
l'immigration dans votre livre sur jean
luc mélenchon vous expliquer qu'il ya un
hiatus entre les militants la france a
ainsi mise majoritairement sans
frontières east on pourrait dire ben
gordon et urban border mais en tout cas
en tout cas ad'ailleurs de sans
frontières de l'immigration et urbain et
une partie de l'électorat qui trouve ans
pour faire simple qui a trop d'immigrés
en france
vous expliquez que le refus de
s'attaquer à cette question est un des
éléments de la chute de la france un
soumise à bien sûr parce que alors si on
déconnecte complètement l'avis des uns
et des autres sur les migrations et
qu'on regarde vous aviez alors on va y
revenir ensuite mais mais quand on
regarde la vie des français c'est très
gentil à vous la majorité des l'immense
majorité des français y compris
d'ailleurs des français qui vote plutôt
à gauche considèrent qu'il ya trop
d'immigrés en france après encore une
fois on va rentrer dans la sémantique
parce que quand les gens entendent
immigrés ils n'entendent pas forcément
le statut administratif immigrés on va
être très clair hier que d'avoir des
français exactement voilà moi je pense
que sans les questions je pense je fais
dit peu cette hypothèse là quand on
demande aux gens est-ce qu'il ya trop
d'immigrés en france il ne pense pas à
la catégorie administrative
il pensa immigrés et descendants
d'immigrés est d'ailleurs à mon avis
c'est pour ça que les chiffres d' hervé
le bras ils existent et ils sont
évidemment exact mais ceci dit si on
considère que le modèle d'intégration
français a des problèmes et que et qu'il
ne fonctionne pas autant que
qu'auparavant il ya des gens qui sont
français qui ne sont pas immigrés mais
qui ne sont pas bien intégrés et en fait
le raisonnement des gens qui vont être
opposés à l'immigration va être de dire
si on continue à avoir des flux qui sont
élevés l'intégration ne pourra pas
marcher
d'autant plus qu'on met tous les
immigrés dans le temps les mêmes ce qui
est un gros problème également
donc à mon avis si je reviens sur
justement
ce qui est arrivé à mélenchon mais ce
qui arrive en réalité à beaucoup de
partis de gauche
c'est que les gens qu'on le veuille ou
non sont globalement en faveur d'une
réduction des flux migratoires y compris
voilà y compris une bonne partie de
l'électorat de gauche
alors non une partie l'électorat de
gauche terre que vous avez raison je
vous rejoins en toute chose juste pas
sur ce dernier point à dire que
l'opinion française
c'est globalement ready globalement
ready sur ces sujets là donc oui
aujourd'hui c'est vrai que il ya tout un
faisceau d'indicateurs en particulier
dans le cas de fractures françaises
inquiètes édité chaque année
qui dit bien que le pays de ce point de
vue là se sentant mal et est de plus en
plus fermé et régulier sur lui-même
terre que la mondialisation est vu comme
une menace
d'accord la proportion de français qui
voit la mondialisation comme une menace
n'a jamais été aussi élevée et même la
proportion de français qui pensent qu'il
ya trop d'étrangers en france
aujourd'hui dans la question à tout le
monde
le var aux 260 donc ses 62 % des
employés dans les centres 15 % des
ouvriers trous sont d'accord avec
l'affirmation vous dites la france
compte déjà beaucoup d'étrangers
accueillir des immigrés supplémentaires
n'est pas souhaitable
oui et mal mais je prends juste un autre
exemple dans mon pied dans mon livre
c'est sûr justement sur les électeurs de
juin que mélenchon en 2017 qui répondent
à une question c'était sûr
l'aquarelliste vous savez ce drap ce
navire peuplé de migrants est-ce qu'il
faut l'accueillir en france
vous avez quand même 50 % des électeurs
de jean une finition en 2017 51 mêmes
qui disaient non alors j'ai fait quand
même quelques événements militants de la
france insoumise et d'autres partis de
gauche d'ailleurs parti socialiste et
europe écologie les verts etc
vous demandez à 100 militants sur une
réunion militante je pense qu'on n'a pas
un qui vous dit il faut pas accueillir à
l'aquarium donc quelque part il ya quand
même un hiatus entre le discours des
partis de gauche et des militants de
gauche et même une partie de leurs
électeurs ouais je nuance quand même
vraiment ce point encore une fois c'est
vrai que pino pascali à une censure
c'est vrai que si l'état ou qu'ils
assument pas devant vous que maintenant
je pense qu'ils assument je pense juste
que les militants sont pas les électeurs
alors encore une fois quand même quand
vous regardez précisément dans quatre
acteurs française sur le sentiment de se
sentir chez soi
la question est posée comme tel jeu
comme s'il il ya un peu plus de 60% des
français qui considèrent qu'on ne se
sent plus chez soi c'est vrai donc le
rejet de leur rejet de l'immigration est
un symptôme dit m
ensuite quand vous regardez quand même
là
précisément les chiffres non ça reste ça
reste un facteur extrêmement clivant je
dirais même que ça reste un dernier
facteur de clivage très puissant entre
la gauche et la droite
et de ce point de vue là c'est dit mais
non seulement il à gauche vaches autant
si la gauche représente je sais pas 15 à
20% aujourd'hui alors qu'elle
représentait 50 % il ya quelques
décennies
c'est peut-être en partie lié à ce thème
là alors en tout cas c'est un vrai sujet
ouais je sais c'est un vrai sujet de la
société politique qui vous dit en citant
john sainte-marie de l'opt de
l'évolution de la partie de l'électorat
populaire de gauche aux fins de l'état
bien sûr de gauche l'électorat populaire
effectivement de ce point de vue là et
je joue davantage au style la limite
tout de suite à paroles mathieu je je je
reprends le donc la thèse du dernier
livre de patrick stefanini donc le
figaro magazine a publié les bonnes
feuilles le week-end dernier où l'on
peut retrouver d'ailleurs sur le sur le
site du figaro et il parle dans son
raisonnement il ya enfin un truc assez
dense observations il repart il reprend
le ce qu'il appelle le seuil de
tolérance cher à françois mitterrand et
il dit que pour beaucoup bien des points
il ce seuil de tolérance est dépassée en
matière d'éducation
18% des enfants immigrés sont sans
diplôme contre 8% sur le chômage
on vient d'en parler la pauvreté près de
40 % contre 11 %
le lot sans parler du logement est ce
qu'il est dans ces conditions bien
raisonnable de d'accueillir et de ne pas
dire la prince temps on arrête
tant qu'on n'a pas des conditions
d'accueil qui sont qui sont optimales
pour accueillir ces nouveaux avions
alors j'ai pas du tout l'ul ni même les
bonnes feuilles du livre de patrick
s'effacer pour ça je fais droite tout à
fait intéressant alors quand vous avez
effectivement les difficultés
d'intégration d'un certain nombre ce fut
là sociale quand vous avez des
difficultés d'intégration d'un certain
nombre de populations soit vous
considérez que le problème effectivement
cédé avoir laissé entrer
soit vous considérez que le problème
c'est de ne pas savoir les intégrer et
de ne pas savoir les uns alors ou
éventuellement les 2 mai mais est
d'ailleurs ensuite philosophiquement on
peut être ou pas d'accord pour
l'ouverture des frontières la porosité
etc
on peut tout à fait admettre qu'il y à
des discriminations dont un certain
nombre de catégories de la population
sont aujourd'hui victimes et donc la
question encore une fois est de savoir
comment précisément on lutte contre ces
discriminations discrimination qui font
que canton
est un descendant d'immigré aussi
français soit on en termes de
nationalité quand on est un descendant
d'immigrés même quand on a fait des
études supérieures avoir un logement
signé un bail pour un logement ou
obtenir un contrat sur la base de son cv
c'est plus difficile que quand on est un
français de souche mais voilà deux
points de vue là et c'est très
intéressant d'ailleurs dans les enquêtes
d'opinion
les français eux mêmes ont conscience
que la société française est raciste
comporte en tout cas on a une forme de
racisme et nourri des discriminations
donc la question c'est est ce qu'on
ferme les frontières et on lutte contre
l'immigration ou est ce que on est
plutôt bien chez nous et on travaille à
diminuer les discriminations dont sont
une partie de nos concitoyens qui pour
la plupart d'entre eux sont français
alors devant ce débat agite la grèce
devant je laisse je vais faire référence
à régis debray la frontière n'est pas
n'est pas un mur c'est une porte
or à mon avis il faut pas avoir cette
manière binaire de présenter les choses
hier que à mon avis l'opposition des
français n'est pas entre des gens qui
veulent qu'ils aient aucun immigré en
france et c'est terminé on ferme
complètement les vannes et des gens qui
disent avec plus de frontières on laisse
entrer tout le monde est à mon avis
c'est beaucoup plus complexe que ça
l'immigration est un sujet extrêmement
complexe qui pose des questions
économiques qu'on a abordé au début qui
pose des questions culturelles qui pose
des questions d'intégration
or à mon avis vous avez tout à fait
raison de dire qu'il ya des
discriminations envers les gens qui sont
immigrées ou descendants des migrants
france a c'est vrai c'est incontestable
ces mesures et etc et on aurait aussi
tout à fait raison de dire que des gens
par exemple dans des banlieues
populaires ont vu leurs environnements
changent et que l'immigration quand elle
est concentrée dans des endroits
spécifiques et quand je sais pas d amy
les immigrés viennent de zones où c'est
moins facile de s'intégrer en france
et bien ce à cause de sa cause aussi des
problèmes par exemple je crois il ya
déjà des données assez précise sur quel
immigrés réussissent mieux à l'école que
d'autres eh bien on voit très bien qu'il
ya des cultures d'origine des pays
d'origine où c'est plus facile pour les
enfants de réussir à l'école que
d'autres donc à mon avis il faut pas
chercher à opposer des fermes et aider
ouvert je sais qu'on aime beaucoup dire
oui il ya des gens qui sont fermées des
gens qui sont ouverts mais la question
de l'intensité des flux migratoires doit
être posée d'ailleurs que moi quand je
vois des villes du 93 ou
je connais des professeurs dont don qui
ont des classes de 30 élèves en à 25
dont les parents parlent pas français à
la maison
est ce que est ce que ces enfants là
peuvent vraiment s'intégrer en france
c'est compliqué vous êtes vous dit vous
avez mille fois raison sur le fait que
enfin la question migratoire est une
question démocratique democratic tout à
fait majeure et donc il faut pouvoir
l'aborder en fait de façon très
tranquille la question quand même c'est
que encore une fois comme je le disais
tout à l'heure la question migratoire
est souvent de façon totalement
fallacieuse reliés à des problématiques
économiques ou à des problèmes de
sécurité ou à des problèmes de
terrorisme récemment qu'ils sont
totalement baroque c'est alors je
comprends pas pourquoi vous dites que
c'est fallacieux
c'est à dire que vous ai dit tout à
l'heure finalement le chômage a augmenté
malgré la fraude a faim et la faim de
l'immigration de travail dans les années
70 est ce que vous faites
al'inverse un lien entre l'augmentation
du chômage et l'avs et l'aï l'arrêt de
l'immigration de travail non non pas du
tout c'est pas du tout et les mâles
sujets ont été le lot est encore une
fois les migrations les migrations au
pluriel
aujourd'hui statistiquement sont moins
importante qu'elle ne l'était à la fin
du 19e siècle
si la france accueillait aujourd'hui
chaque année autant d'immigrants que les
etats-unis non non non non non acceptés
à la fin du dix neuvième siècle on
aurait un million d'entrées chaque année
donc le monde aujourd'hui est beaucoup
moins ouvert en réalité qu'on ne veut
bien le dire aimer mais évidemment comme
les débats sont souvent un peu simplifié
et que par ailleurs on fait référence là
où aller a en fait appel ou à des
fantasmes ou encore une fois à des idées
reçues on s'y perd un peu rien la
société vraiment aujourd'hui et plus
faire avant que l'étaient les états unis
6es jeux je termine je cherche sur ce
raisonnement il ya peut-être aussi des
fantasmes mais aussi des faits serre
qu'il ya des questions que les gens se
posent et en particulier les internautes
par exemple dans la sphère de l'attentât
de nice où on a un clandestin qui est
venu sans vraisemblement ces
informations qu'on a eu vraiment pour
pour tuer pour commettre cet attentat
en tous les cas en l'état actuel de
l'enquêté des informations dont on
dispose on peut poser la question mais
la loi ne va pas dire que c'est pas que
c'est fallacieux
mais je ne dis pas qu'il n'ya pas
parfois des attentats ou des crimes ou
des délits qui sont commis par des
étrangers ou même par des descendants
dit
grise à ben c'est pas le problème mais
c'est pas parce que encore une fois un
tunisien franchi la frontière et vient
comme ça l'a lu ça dans la sphère des
attentats de 2002 2015 aussi mais bien
sûr mais enfin il ya beaucoup plus
d'attentats qui sont encore une fois
réalisées par des français que par des
gens qui traversent la frontière pour
commettre un attentat
donc on peut se dire parce qu'un
tunisien est venu à nice et a commis des
actes tout à fait affreuse une sorte une
sortie d'église
on ferme la frontière ça n'a pas de sens
on est quand même dans un monde ouvert
et encore une fois je n'y a pas de six
lits à la première le soir il ya des
attentats du bataclan serre qui ferment
des frontières mais elle est en tout cas
il remet le contrôle aux frontières et
donc tu es loin on reprend la maîtrise
de l'institution comme ça mais encore
une fois il ya moins de personnes qui
circulent aujourd'hui
et voilà je ne sais pas se fermer les
frontières ne règlerait absolument pas
ces problèmes là non il ne s'agit pas de
les fermer toute façon c'est vrai c'est
surtout dû mettre le contrôle elle parle
juste en fait sur le terrorisme celle
inverse
non seulement il faut pas fermer les
frontières mais en réalité la meilleure
la meilleure réponse est là en
l'occurrence les spécialistes du
renseignement les 10 c'est pas la
fermeture des frontières c'est la
coopération entre les pays
et c'est en particulier la coopération
entre les services de renseignement on
sait pas ce que vous faisiez référence à
l'attentât 2015 qu'un des gros problème
précisément c'est la coopération entre
les systèmes de renseignement et la
transmission d'information entre
systèmes de renseignement français et
belges
les frontières mais qu'on travaillait de
façon beaucoup plus coopérative les
différents pays entre eux on éviterait
encore plus d'attendre là qu'on ne le
fait pas aujourd'hui se situe sur la
coopération est quand même de sacrés
problèmes notamment quand on veut
expulser des gens dont le droit d'asile
a été refusée et bien sûr le taux de
délivrance dans les délais parce qu'en
fait quand vous les expulser quelqu'un
il faut que vous ayez invalider une
validation consulaire de la part du pays
pour le gabon c'est zéro pour cent ans
pour l'afghanistan c'est 20%
oui pour l'inde l'irak le mali le
pakistan dont l'un des pays moi vivons
des ressortissants un peu problématique
des fois c'est de 20% ou non aux
arrestations en ce moment au pakistan
voisin pas très francophone voilà ça n'a
pas l'air a appelé très amateur de la
culture française donc en tout cas ça
pose des vrais problèmes
mais ceci dit sur la question que vous
posez il faut quand même regarder les
choses en face c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui on débat où il ya le ce
moratoire qui à mon avis est en partie
une mesure de communication mais on
débat de l'intensité des flux
migratoires posant les choses clairement
des flux migratoires moins fort depuis
50 ans le problème de l'islamisme en
france ne poserait pas la même manière
il faut être honnête il faut le dire de
manière très claire quoi c'est un stand
de problèmes sociaux en france qui sont
nés de l'intensité des flux migratoires
ou et aujourd'hui c'est aujourd'hui une
bonne partie de ces gens là sont
français force est de constater qu'il ya
un problème en france et que il est en
partie liée à l'immigration
je ne dis pas que l'immigration est un
phénomène diabolique en soi mais on peut
se poser la question que la question
c'est l'ampleur qu'on accorde à ce
phénomène ou pas henri thé et je feins
je ne suis pas sûr et d'ailleurs à ce
stade encore une fois la question
migratoire ne figure pas en tête des
préoccupations des français
peut-être le deviendra tél al'approche
de la présidentielle aujourd'hui elle
est reléguée loin évidemment derrière
les questions sanitaires sur
l'économique les questions sociales et
même les questions environnementales
voilà ensuite les gens évidemment mais
entre temps les questions de sécurité
les gens vont évidemment s'intéresser à
aux questions qu'on va aussi leur mettre
sur la table
merci donc si on souhaite que les
français s'intéressent à la question
migratoire forcément le fera encore une
fois le front national depuis toujours
tente d'associer question migratoire
questions sanitaires restions social
questions économiques et malheureusement
il y est parvenu ce sera ma dernière
question peut-être à devenir le front
national c'est incontestablement dans
les années 70 à l'époque lou également
le parti communiste georges marchais
alors lutter sur le sur l'aspect plutôt
économique
mais georges marchais avait avait eu des
discours très dur sur l'immigration qui
bon après c'était c'était du marxiste
dans le texte on c'est à dire que
l'immigration serait l'armée de réserve
du capital c'est à dire que quand vous
quand vous les mettre en concurrence les
travailleurs entre eux vous fait rentrer
des travailleurs qui sont prêts à
travailler pour pour rien pour des
clopinettes et en plus bon il ya sept
les patrons peuvent embaucher des
salariés moins cher et en plus ça brise
un petit peu la solidarité du
prolétariat avec des avec les
différences culturelles mon sas pour le
coup c'est du marx dans un discours que
parfois la sensation mise reprend encore
aujourd'hui alors il ya un petit peu
moins difficile 2017
oui oui vous pouvez lire la suite dans
le vent la ville donne rien mettre tout
mélenchon la chute comment la france a
soumis s'est effondré c'est formidable
c'est intéressant ce débat ils peuvent
pas s'expliquer dans le calme c'est ce
que nous dit christian virus a
effectivement c'est ça bonjour va
jusqu'au bout de nos points de vue
jusqu'au bout dé nos désaccords c'est le
principe même de cette émission mathieu
su pierre n'a pas de tort nous dit
babineau l'immigration est aussi un bouc
émissaire pour justifier de
l'aggravation de certains facteurs
jean-paul sur la même ligne en fait le
seul défaut des émigrés d'accepter les
emplois dont personne ne veut plus être
vu que c'est un petit peu plus compliqué
sur les dernières statistiques
ils rament la question c'est de
sécuriser les frontières fermer nos
frontières n'empêche pas les terroristes
devenir christophe 78 me dit également
que georges marchais 10 et il faut
stopper l'immigration légale et
clandestine
et si tu nous lis les mouvements
migratoires massifs ça commence aprés
guerre voir avec le regroupement
familial non en famille à lille vient à
petits pas prêts dans les années c'est
carrément dans les années 70 et l'autre
intérêt d'ailleurs du guide patrick
stefanini dans tout ce qu'on peut dire
c'est que le regroupement familial qui
consiste à faire venir sa famille quand
on aime quelqu'un et de faim
ressortissant d'un pays c'est à dire ces
enfants sont du coup d'état en fait
c'est peu une petite partie de ce
regroupement familial vrai le vrai
regroupement final aujourd'hui c'est
quelqu'un arrive en france
ici se marie avec un élan avec quelques
avec leurs ressortissants et
ressortissants tous ressortissants de
son pays
et c'est comme ça que il il ya une
arrivée comme ça c'est ce que j'ai
appris en tout cas en lisant ce livre
donc le livre de patrick stefanini chez
albin michel les bonnes pages sont à
retrouver les bonnes feuilles sont à
retrouver sur le site du figaro merci
beaucoup mathieu merci et on se retrouve
très vite sur figaro live demain vous
retrouver guillaume roquette même heure
même endroit
[Musique]